[Applause]
foreign
good time good times
happy Monday everybody so CNN did
another stupid hilarious thing and this
time the punch line is not Chris Wallace
wow tough crowd today huh
I don't know if I want to continue the
show
anyway they introduced the world to the
phrase Neo pronouns yeah last Saturday
CNN published a guide to Neo pronouns
where they offered their preferred
pronouns which includes zazer fafer and
a ER
yeah those are about as common as a
picture of Hunter Biden wearing pants
Dennis Baron a professor told CNN Neo
pronouns should be used and respected
like any other pronoun yeah Danny I'm
gonna go on a limb and say you're out of
luck this is over the only people who
still take this crap seriously are
interns at CNN forced to interview
idiots like you
CNN quoted other dopes saying
neopronouns are a reflection of
someone's personal identity well I'll
give them that if you're a loser a
nobody or in more specific terms a boar
because only boring lazy people need a
Neo pronoun if you're boring it adds
Pizzazz and if you're lazy you don't
have to do anything other than say I'm a
z
how lame is this a maida pronoun is now
a participation trophy for people who
can't participate in actual life it's a
built-in excuse for people going nowhere
without having to travel to Delaware
I don't know
people who list their pronouns are worse
than people who list I drive stick under
Hobbies on their resume
because I can't
wow you guys
what what's in your coffee
but they're like people who say they're
spiritual but not religious they get
tattoos so people can ask them about
their tattoos they wear t-shirts of
bands they don't listen to they get
degrees in subjects that aren't useful
to anyone they brag when they've read a
book their parents are usually well off
and provided a good life for them but
yet they still hate capitalism they're
the most boring people on the planet
even ahead of those who buy books by
Brian Kilmeade
but it does beg the obvious question
what makes an interesting person and is
it that hard to be interesting or you
should ask who interested you first as a
child remember it was old people
grandparents they were magical it was so
cool to see them constantly smoking
they had something that wasn't defined
for you perhaps it was called wisdom
mixed with whiskey but they had Tales of
Wars life Love and Death their failures
and their accomplishments they could
show you a grainy black and white photo
and talk about a cousin who died at 19
but had more experiences than most
people now do in a lifetime
but what about later you're a teen
you're young and shy you haven't
discovered my books which are on tape
what might make you interesting without
falling for or following the pronoun
sheep we'll try reading in books not
threads listen to people travel exercise
learn skills like cooking or hunting
become good at something it's not that
hard trust me
for example no one has ever failed at
trying to be a DJ you just play music on
a computer
and when people find out that you know
how to do stuff they're interested I
once dated a girl who killed her own
dinner I found that sexy she introduced
me to another girl who claimed she was a
witch
and she tasted delicious
people who have hobbies or play a sport
or just do things any things that stuff
is interesting I don't care if it's
cornhole or calligraphy as long as it's
not jazz
but people who do things are more
interesting than people who identify
things because they actually accomplish
something I find that the pronoun peeps
don't do anything but tell you who they
are it's why they can never afford to
pay for lunch while they spent their
allowance on a haircut that looks like
an industrial accident
but an interesting person prefers
individuals over groups and finds the
world more interesting than how the
world perceives them meanwhile a boring
person expects you to find interest in
them
people who list their pronouns are
boring or else they wouldn't list them
they literally have nothing better to do
they see how easy it is to get attention
it's as easy as breaking a woman's
weightlifting record
she is Louise what's wrong with these
people
laughs this is gold here people I know
they're like they're like yeah you ever
seen gold before
I would hate to sit next to someone on a
plane who goes by anything other than he
and she it's why I fly private
but choosing a new pronoun means you've
mistaken momentary attention from others
for genuine interest in you and you have
no other skills or charms because you
stopped at Z when people pay attention
to you for that for a moment you become
special but it's downhill from there
like marrying cat
we're very happy
so it's over time to shut down the fake
pronouns if someone demands you to
adhere tell them your pronouns are and
off
promoting a fake attribute the pronoun
makes gender the overriding principle in
your life so you actually stop doing
anything else of note you're not only
boring now you're boring forever I mean
at least you can put your pronouns on
Your Grave this is too bad no one will
bother to visit
[Applause]
if the prince is a vampire she's a
wooden cross
Haley magazine
like his family dinners he's a one-man
show actor writer and comedian Jamie
Lisa
when I am pesty she gets testy Fox News
contributor tattoo
and even his common sense is immense my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion
Jamie um good to see you as always are
you non-binary
um I'm I don't I think I'm the other one
yeah is it binary yeah I guess you're
binary I Googled all the words we were
going to talk about tonight and that
wasn't one of them so I'm not sure what
it means
um
did any did any pronouns strike your
fancy you know what here by the way if
anybody doesn't know what a pronoun is
just give you I'll give you like a
random like couple sentences of what
pronouns are it would be like um she
divorced him for no reason
um he was really sad these are just
random right you know like right lived
in the house yeah that he bought
um he dodged a bullet yeah
it's so CR I feel attacked from the
monologue too because you know I think
you knew I I have a tattoo that says ask
me about my tattoo yeah and so I feel
really attached nothing is safe anymore
right words I'm surprised they haven't
taken the dick out of dictionary at this
point
yeah
um and you know me I'm a comedian so my
pronouns are hehe
um
it's cute that was pretty that's like a
that's a joke for all the ages yeah
that's what I'm going for when I'm on
stage instead of people like laughing
really loud I hope they all go that's
cute
[Laughter]
same thing when you're naked yeah but
isn't it it's
I don't even know why I said that that
is crazy at that point you should yeah
to move on from you uh Jamie you've
depressed me Kaylee two children correct
I do what happened happens when one of
them is old enough to come in hopefully
all of this stuff will be gone by now I
think it's like a momentary delusion
like a flash flood of stupidity I hope
so and it will disappear but let's say
you're one of your kids you have two
daughters no a daughter and a son but I
guess in this day and age it's anyone's
determination yeah we're not sure yet
what your the gender of your children
are Kaylee yes all right I'll be the
judge later when I review the court
papers no um what do you tell them if
some if somebody says you know
don't commit a civil rights violation in
kindergarten that's what I tell them no
it's all seriousness I went to I believe
was one of the Dakotas it was somewhere
in the Midwest and someone said to me a
mom was like my kids go to school and
every day these kids come with a
different pronoun they think it's a joke
yeah my kid was getting in trouble sent
to detention because they weren't
corresponding to the right pronoun like
this is where we are as a society I
really want to know why you made me read
a CNN article about Neo pronouns today
that was like the worst task on my list
of things to do today
um I thought it was weird because it's
like basically this this this this ship
is sailed I really think the pronoun
thing is over but I see this and I'm
like going like what is CNN doing what
they're they're like I don't know well
here's one thing I learned you can
choose any noun and put self at the end
and it becomes a pronoun so like they
use the example of leaf someone can say
I'm a leaf I'm a leaf and you have to
refer to me as Leaf self and if you
don't refer to me as Leaf self you've
committed a civil rights violation so
that's the insanity with which we were
at it's in the CNN article buried in
like paragraph 42. So Leaf self is a
pronoun that's what I like about having
Kaylee on cat because she reads all the
way to the end generally I
I will like I will do the headline maybe
a paragraph and then I will yell at
somebody just scream at somebody and
then I'll just go to sleep
that's what I do that's and one day you
can be just like me cat
that sure is the goal
no I I read the whole thing too I was
actually writing about some of this
stuff years and years ago at National
Review and I look if anybody came up to
me and said like any of this stuff I'd
just be like
okay yeah which you're right could
potentially devastate that person right
uh I don't think that it's real I I
looked this up on Twitter trying to find
somebody who's like a real human with
like a name and a picture of their face
being like thank you CNN for talking
about this yes so I I don't think it's
really all that much of a thing but the
kit kids doing it doesn't shock me
because if I were a kid and this sort of
thing I wouldn't have a new pronoun
every single day every day I would love
that attention yeah when I was in first
grade like there was boys that were
really bad troublemakers so they had
this little chart where they got a star
if they were good and I was like well I
gotta start behaving worse so then I can
get more attention yes that's true there
was a kid in my third grade class that
decided she would be a cat all day yeah
so now you can actually do that and get
rewarded
yeah okay we're just gonna stop this
party all right the answer is no no no I
don't want to know if if I if someone
comes up to me and they can't say hi I'm
Daryl yeah I'm like hi my pronouns are
they will the wind of me walking away
from them will knock them over
like I'm not participating in your games
I got I got real things going on
and cats
cats right
when you look for people who actually
are going through this when you find
them you understand why
they're always the same they have the
same look it's either a a faux hawk with
some really bad hair coloring a horrible
nose piercing really the appropriate bad
tattoos that they're going to regret
whenever they decide to grow up and
they're going to cry for help and it's
your monologue was spot on like they
don't participate they don't they they
can't succeed they're not trying to
succeed so I will make myself something
different so I can win in my event right
because I'm the Unicorn Leaf itself
and there's only one of me I I did some
research too cat yeah and everyone I
found it was like one guy was like I'm
half vampire and half uh light control
because my parents were werewolf my
parents was the vampire so I have both
their powers and when I find someone
attractive my eyes itch
y Insanity
you stay away from those people exactly
keep your pronouns on Twitter so we can
avoid you and if my kids came home and
said Daddy my pronouns is this this and
this yeah my pronoun would be ass
whooping yeah I I will I will sit in
detention with you I'll bring cake and
pie okay hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else